[Musique]
on
luzia mamouth moreau bon jour en jour
charbonnel bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur le plateau de tv soixante dix
huit pour un vip qui est consacrée à la
troisième édition de la biennale
versaillaise
alors je vous présente tous hier vous
êtes beaucoup de choses à la fois vous
êtes à la fois artiste peintre auteur
compositeur chanteuse et surtout pour le
moment ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
vous êtes l'organisatrice la commissaire
le commissaire de cette fameuse biennale
versaillaise qui aura lieu du 3 au 8
avril au carré à la farine au carré à la
farine a versé à versailles
voilà ouvert tous les jours de 12h à 19h
au dimanche de 12 19 heures et xavier et
christophe charbonnel vous êtes là à ce
que vous êtes noir vous êtes surtout
sculpteur voilà et vous êtes l'invité
d'honneur de cette fameuse biennale
il ya deux invités d'honneur cette année
donc à savoir vous christophe cha bonal
et marie angèle castello costumes
castillo exact on voit là alors on va
parler un petit peu de vous et de cette
biennale qui existe donc depuis six ans
puisque trois fois de 6 chez moi oui
c'est ça donc ça a commencé en 2012
voilà qu'est ce qui vous est donné cette
envie d'organiser un événement comme
cela alors j'ai rentré de rio à cette
époque
oui et j'avais les cas et à la farine
pour une exposition au personnel
d'accord et je suis allé rencontrer
philippe les jeunes je ferais compter
les calories au mieux jeunes voilà c'est
le fondateur d'une école qui s'appelle
l'école des temps l'école des tempes
exact que vous avez fréquenté aussi ou
pas du tout non pas du tout ok et donc
et donc je suis allé les visites et
parce qu'il allait plus dans l'atelier
des tombes
ouais et il n'était pas très en forme et
j'ai posé la question est ce que vous
voulez qu'on organise une exposition
dont vous serez l'invité d'honneur et ça
lui a donné
vraiment la pêche il était tout content
et ça a été ton de moi ça a été monté la
première biennale et d'envié tous les
deux non habitée j'ai appelé du coup
vous émerveiller d'autres hasard si les
artistes les plus importants de l'école
des tombes qui tout le monde a été
partisan et donc on a fait cette
première biennale pour philippe les
jeunes donc invité d'honneur on était
douze artistes est vaste et en 2000 en
2012 voilà deux invités en avril 2012
voilà et il est décédé quelques jours
avant l'ouverture à ça c'est des salons
voilà et donc depuis on a toujours une
offre de philippe les jeunes dont les
salons comme cette fois ci encore et que
dire de sa lune souvenir de sa mémoire
d'ailleurs la première biennale c'est
devenu sa première exposition posthume
d'un corps du fait d'accord et alors
comment ça se passe là par exemple
labinal la troisième la qui va avoir
lieu donc en avril combien d'artistes
exposent alors soixante dix neuf
artistes y compris christophe charbonnel
louis barrière gel castillo et les
invités d'honneur et philippe les jeunes
donc philippe lejeune à un tableau vous
vous exposez aussi un tableau j'expose
aussi un tableau d'accord et bacon va
qu'on verra tout pour ma petite voix et
dites moi alors comment comment est
perçue cette exposition à balansun de
tableau c'est oui c'est ça mon tableau
vous êtes d'origine brésilienne faut ni
tout à fait alors ses tableaux sont
alors ses tableaux c'était un tableau de
là bas justement parce que ces cds dans
des rues
a confié le président exact de bâle ii
par chez vous oui très bien
ok et à l'heure du conte vous avez 79
artistes mais ça paraît juste énorme
c'est énorme et c'est très grand ce lieu
comme un espace c'est pas très grand et
il a 180 m² ouais mais c'est vrai que
christophe chabot adele a attiré
beaucoup plus des sculpteurs cette année
donc on a eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de demandes et j'aime et je me suis dit
c'est tellement très bien tous les
artistes qui se sont présentés on
pouvait pas exclure
donc je vois et définir les choix et
était très difficile d'accord et mais
c'est bien c'est quand même très très
très serré avec l'opposition ça c'est
moi j'avais autant d'atteintes aux
réunions mais dans un même lieu
c'est un évitement alors on a donc des
peintres et sculpteurs et sculpteurs et
voilà c'est pas grave vu cette année on
n'a pas eu des graveurs d'accord ok très
bien mais écoutez merci monsieur pour
cette belle initiative et puis on vous
donne rendez vous très vite donc en
avril du 3 au 8 pour venir voir votre
belle exposition
alors christophe chabot neil je me
tourne vers vous vous êtes donc artistes
sculpteurs ou dix sculpteurs mode leur
scooter du sculpteur mais j'aime bien le
terme mode l'heure parce que pour moi il
est très parlant vous travaillez quel
matériel dans l'argile principalement
ouais les battre et le plâtre et ça fait
combien de temps que vous travaillez en
tant que sculpteur danseuse
professionnelle alors
professionnellement ça fait une
quinzaine d'années maintenant mais je
l'annoncé à faire du modelage ya 25 ans
après avoir rencontré philippe sénéque
ima
appris pendant deux ans areva et cnnc
l'atelier
alors c'était l'école duperré ah oui
nicole dupéré voilà il est donc cours du
soir la mairie de paris dont à l'époque
c'était très peu cher je pouvais avoir
accès à tout un savoir qui manquait en
fait faux bond à tresser pas votre
formation initiale n'ont absolument pas
je vous avez fait quoi je faisais plein
de choses et vous avez travaillé
notamment à val d'isère à mon travail
j'ai travaillé à montreuil pour le
studio walt disney et vous faisiez quoi
du dessin animé et j'étais assistant
assistant déjà dans l'amateur artistique
la pratique du dessin voilà donc vous
êtes arrivé dans les yvelines ya quand
même temps il ya une quinzaine d'années
voilà donc vous avez pu avoir un grand
atelier j'imagine du coup tout à fait
dans la norme faire et là vous vous êtes
attaqués à votre passion voilà le
modelage qui implique tout un travail de
soudure tout un travail de moulage est
ce que vous faites une armature ont fait
les normes mature maintenant ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que vos sculptures sont
plutôt pas monumental oui monumentales
on le le terme c'est monumental mais
après je travaille surtout la verna oui
j'ai fait de pas rester bloqué sur sur
sur un format encore mais du coup les
armatures sont nécessaires pour les très
grandes
oui pour les pêcheries pour le footing
ce testing et pourquoi alors parce que
je ne fais pas cuire mes terres
je moule donc je monte sur une armature
qui me permet ajouté la terre allard
matière j'ajoute la terre l'armature ce
qui me permet d'avoir une culture assez
l'ariane puisqu'il ya un squelette qui
maintient la pièce est non alors elle
est pleine ah ben non c'est plein gré
pour moi rien s'est plaint en fait
enfin ça c'est une technique qui
s'appelle c'est le travail par les
profils travail par les profils donc ça
consiste en c'est à dire il faut monter
jusqu'à la forme un tailleur de pierre
va descendre jusqu'à la forme qu'à un un
moddeur lui va monter jusqu'à la fin
pour âge on rajoute du rajout tact donc
on part d'une on peut voir sur les
photos
cette magnifique photo de ce que le tien
jeu qu'on voit ici par exemple
c'est un travail de modelage donc on
voit bien différentes strates qui me qui
m'amène juste voilà elle mène jusqu'à la
forme par exemple qui est qu'il a dans
la geôle dans la joue c'est une trace de
ce qui s'est passé avant et je laisse
vivre ça me permet de parler de
l'historique ou si la pièce de comment
elle a été montée et 2 et 2 pour les
gens qui sont pour le public un petit
peu avertis te commencé à considérer
toutes les histoires de moulage toutes
les histoires de dépouilles contre
dépouilles sont oui des choses assez
technique en fait de quoi des pouilly
contre dépouille c'est celle à la base
du moulage hk se passe mais c'est bien
on apprend des mois et dites moi où sont
visibles vos oeuvres à part bientôt à la
biennale versaillaise à la galerie baya
qui est 17 rue du buzzer ouais et qui
ouvre aussi une galerie une expo
permanente pour c'est une expo
permanente et qui travaille aussi au
touquet donc oui comme ça
je présume turbo du poumon est aussi
il ya un christ de christophe charbonnel
qu'on vous avez commandé je pense qu'il
ya un peu voyagé dans la vallée de
chevaux oui tout à fait mais il est où
maintenant aller à l'église de saint
rémy les chevreuse il ya toujours et
j'ai toujours dit qu'on allait voir là
je te fais voilà et ya pas une oeuvre
aussi dans un lieu public une deuxième
alors on à bonnes elles dans mon village
les mains de la fontaine voilà vous avez
fait la fontaine qu'on a fait avec avec
les enfants de l'école
voilà qui était un projet extrêmement
intéressant mené par équipe ou pas aussi
été le maire de bonnel d'accord et qui
nous a bien soutenus et bien accompagner
dans cette histoire d'accord donc on
peut aller dans la vallée de chevreuse
pourvoir au moins ces deux oeuvres voila
voila et vous est-ce que vous donnez des
cours non je donne plus de cours
c'est fini c'est fini aa c'est fini
parce que je veux je vous dis ça parce
que j'ai vu sur une vidéo
vous intervenez je restais à mont de
marsan où je sais plus et vous expliquer
notre technique
oui alors de temps en temps c'est le cas
justement mont de marsan
bon je pars demain mont-de-marsan
président pour faire une démonstration
de modelage pour expliquer aux écoles on
pourra intervenir dans les écoles et
montrer ce que peut être le modelage et
comment on peut s'amuser avec de la
terre vous faites pas je les fais mais
je ne fais plus j'ai plus le temps fait
des ouais j'ai touché beaucoup travaillé
d'accord mais c'est génial
vous êtes heureux c'est que ça marche
donc vous avez des sculptures vos thèmes
favoris sont les guerriers les colosses
lui toulouges la mythologie tout ça
vient cette inspiration
je pense que c'est des rêves de gosse
c'est ça le tout par dynacore de héros
vous rêviez de faire petit ouais ouais
tout à fait sérieux déjà ouais ouais bah
je voulais je voulais sortir de je
voulais avoir une vie différente de
celle que l'équipe s'était dit mme était
destiné j'ai eu beaucoup de chance au
génial bah oui on se donne les moyens
d'avoir la chance votre sculpture on la
qualifie de nez aux classes
que vous a peut-être forbid avoir une
étiquette ouais c'est ça c'est bon c'est
un nouveau retard
c'est ça je voulais dire je fais un
travail
j'aime cette j'aime beaucoup la bande
dessinée j'aime beaucoup le cinéma
d'animation j'aime beaucoup tout un tas
de choses
j'aime ce côté narratif et on voit des
sculptures en groupe aussi oui on va
dire que c'est us et une base classique
c'est une base classique on croit dire
néo classique on pourrait dire
figuration narrative dakar est employé
le plein de termes voilà après j'essaye
de m'inscrire dans la lignée des andes
en terre n'est pas cuite
voilà matériel patiner après on ferme
houle donc je fais ma terre je fais un
moule on fait un tirage à l'intérieur du
moule on patine la pièce est ensuite
cette pièce là elle confié au fondeur
qui va lui refaire un moule dessus pour
éditer des bronzes
je vous remercie beaucoup on se donne
rendez vous en avril à quelle heure
petit 18h30 à partir d' à partir de
18h30 jusqu'à 21h jusqu'à 21h super et
il y aura la musique peut-être oui il
aura un petit peu de musique la musique
quoi se la musique brésilienne atteint
là bas ça ma vraie visa merci beaucoup
monsieur lui rendez-vous à la biennale
bien ça y est wen au revoir merci
[Musique]